hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Caroll we've
talked about quantum mechanics a lot on
the podcast you may have heard that I am
a fan of the everan many worlds
formulation of quantum mechanics but we
have a special treat in that we have a
guest who actually met Hugh Everett and
was influenced by him and has gone on to
be a major proponent of the everan
version of quantum mechanics that would
of course be David Deutsch and despite
that despite the fact that David is uh
very well known in his work in quantum
mechanics and Quantum field Theory uh he
was basically if you have to give credit
to one person for pioneering the idea of
quantum computers it would have to be
David do there's other people who made
very significant contributions there but
David was one of the first to really
Define what it means to do a Quantum
computation to write down an algorithm
that was faster than a classical
algorithm to really think about how
entanglement can help you encrypt things
using quantum mechanics and so on it's
been super duper influential he's been
awarded various prizes for this the
Breakthrough prize The Fellowship of the
Royal Society and so forth but that's
not all and in fact in this podcast
we're not even going to talk about
quantum mechanics that much we're going
to be talking about various things that
David has been thinking about that grow
out of arguably his combination of in
the fundamental laws of physics but also
in
epistemology how we learn things about
the world you know we heard you've heard
me talk about quantum mechanics and
Everett you've also maybe heard me talk
about basian reasoning and basian
inference and epistemology and so unlike
quantum mechanics where David and I are
very much on the same team here we are
not and so that's what I wanted to talk
about uh he's been thinking a lot about
I I guess what you might call paparian
epistemology after Carl poer the idea
that we think about possible worlds and
we divide them into the ones that are
compatible with the data and then not
and then seek the best explanation it's
a little bit fuzzy I got to say uh what
counts is the best explanation but it's
clearly also very similar to what we
actually do I mean you can recognize
this in the actual progress of science
we try to come up with the best
explanation for what the world is doing
given the data we currently have and a
way to go beyond that so David has been
trying to formalize that uh thinking
about it very carefully and pointing out
where traditional motos that one invokes
in the basian context might be hiding
some subtleties that make them less
applicable than you might think in
particular there is a theorem due to
Carl popper and ah Miller I don't know
what Miller's first name was but the
popper Miller theorem uh that David has
been thinking about that he would argue
and I think you know there's a case to
be made uh makes it hard to accept
traditional basian vocabulary as how we
really go about picking our theories so
that's a very interesting conversation
to have and another thing that David has
been interested in is Constructor Theory
I don't know if you listened to the
podcast we did a while ago with Kiara
marletto who is uh David's collaborator
in this they've been developing
literally an entirely new
to think about what it means to do
physics to be a law of physics rather
than having some dynamical law where you
start with initial conditions and just
chug forward they think about physics
and not just physics but also biology
chemistry Etc in terms of what is
possible what is not possible and what
kind of Constructors can actually make
things happen in the world I don't know
I still don't know after talking to K
right now to David I still don't know
whether this is going to be super super
duper useful going forward it might very
well be though I'm very open to that I'm
very interested in seeing where that
goes so we talk about that too we talk
about the space of possibilities and how
knowledge and explanation have bursted
onto the scene in the universe with the
Advent of human beings and and their
brains and he's very careful to say it's
not just necessarily human beings aliens
computers could also qualify but it's a
it's a dramatic shift in How the
Universe evolves when you have systems
that can think store information come up
with explanations use that knowledge to
transform the world around them it's
ultimately an optimistic perspective on
the world and that's something uh we
could all use a little bit more of so I
think this is going to be a fun
conversation occasional reminders that
we have a patreon page here at the
mindscape podcast you can go to
patreon.com shanm Caroll kick in a
dollar or two per episode and the
benefits will just start flowing your
way the benefits are not huge but
there's still benefits you get an adree
version of the podcast you get to ask am
questions you get to participate in
those discussions and also after every
podcast I do a little reflection video
and audio that is for patreon members
only so join the fun there patreon.com
shmc Caroll with that let's
[Music]
go
David deuts welcome to the mindscape
podcast hi thanks for inviting me I have
to start we're going to get into
substantive stuff soon enough but I I've
got to start with a question I've had
for a long time I believe that you are
in the audience for a seminar given by
Hugh Everett at the University of Texas
sometime back is that true and indeed I
was can you say was that uh was it
actually kind of a formative experience
what was it like what was you ever like
um it was a memorable experience um uh I
I had imagined him differently and uh
and uh I I knew that wheeler invited him
I was quite excited that that he'
invited him because um uh very few
people were everettian at the time I
suppose very few are now still but but
um yeah sorry this is the
70s uh this was uh yes in the 70s late
'70s
uh so wheeler had had invited him and
was treating him like royalty and one
example I remember I can't remember
exact details but one example I remember
is that there was strict no smoking rule
in the seminar room
and um you know that was quite rare in
those days I mean it hadn't yet become
ubiquitous like it is now um but wheeler
asked for this to be waved in the case
of Everett because he was a chain smoker
he he didn't stop
smoking and uh so this you know leaning
over backwards to to make him feel
comfortable and uh he gave a talk uh
about the Everett interpretation or
everettian quantum theory as we now
prefer to call it um and then uh we went
to have lunch because the the um
graduate students and the postdocs and
the The Faculty on our floor often used
to go and have lunch in one of the
places in Austin and Bryce
DeWit um contrived to have me sit next
to Everett a so uh I had lunch uh
chatting to Everett and I asked him some
you know Elementary questions I hadn't
really started thinking very seriously
about about um it and I I was just very
um
impressed that he was completely on the
ball you know up to dat um with with all
the nuances and so um and we had a nice
chat and that was the last I saw of him
well that was my impression that I only
got from finally writing a book about
writing quantum mechanics was that you
know he only wrote the one paper and
we've all known physicists or scientists
who have the one paper and they move on
and maybe they were right place right
time but you get the impression that he
really did very much understand all the
nuances that was were going on it wasn't
just that he got
lucky yeah very much so and I got the
impression although I know other people
uh you know have a different history in
mind but I got the impression that he
did not
leave research in physics because he was
disappointed at the reception his ideas
got or anything like that he left it
because he wanted to do other things and
to make a fortune and and you know he
did you know it's uh that's perfectly
valid and I also got that impression and
you were it sounds like you were Everett
sympathetic even before that talk but
did that inspire you to think more
carefully about it yes I was Everett
sympathetic because of dwit yeah so uh I
was lucky in that respect so I I met DT
and then a couple of years I can't
remember how long later Everett so I met
dwit when DT was on sabatical in Oxford
ah and I was a graduate student I was a
first year graduate student and uh there
again not by anyone's contriving but by
sheer chance um I was in Dennis sharma's
department and we we went to have um a
lunch at a pizza place in little
Clarendon Street in Oxford and I
happened to be sitting opposite DT uh
and I only vaguely remembered that DT
had something to do with the Everett
interpretation so I thought well I'll
ask him and he I asked him a very silly
question I can't remember exactly what
it was and something like um um you know
if there are many copies of me which am
I or you know something like that
something as Elementary as that and um
and he was very kind and uh explained to
me that that this was not a good
question and the way to think about this
was you know and and he explained it to
me and and uh and then I asked some more
questions and uh By the time we'd
finished lunch I was I was completely
convinced I mean previously I had
already thought this was worth looking
into because it it was a version of
quantum theory that was purely physics
and didn't have any kind of me
uh psychology or assumptions about the
brain and and that kind of thing this
was just how we'd been taught to to deal
with theories and um and so but but what
convinced me uh was that lunch with do
it it it's a it actually leads into to
the broader conversation because you're
giving examples of how the space of
possibilities in life is very very large
and Tiny unexpected events can can steer
you in one direction or another well yes
I mean I think that's true but I'm not
sure that these examples were examples
of it because uh I'm not sure well I'd
like to think anyway that I wasn't
exactly steered I I was just
hastened uh I I think I would have come
round to this event
if for no other reason then I would
eventually have read Dot's work on this
and everetts and I would have talked to
Wheeler about it and been dissatisfied
with his
answer so you know I I think that would
have happened there's some convergent
evolution there yeah yeah exactly so
good we've already mentioned that uh
there's a lot of things to talk about
but uh I I've chosen as the the
substantive starting point monotony you
gave a nice little Ted Talk on uh the
end of monotony and how we're moving
into a different era I I thought that
the title of the talk was was maybe not
the most inspiring and maybe you would
get more clicks if it were if it were
not about monotony but maybe you could
explain what the basic idea there is as
always the titles are not chosen by the
author that that title was not chosen by
me so yes it seems that progress
is not uniformly rapid and progress in
various senses like the the uh origin of
of planets like ours uh and the origin
of life like ours and the origin of
multicellular life and the origin of um
uh of explanatory creativity uh as in
humans and then the origin of of um the
explosion of of the Enlightenment all
those things happened very rapidly after
a long period of not happening and in
all cases you can't really put your
finger on why uh why it took so long uh
I mean I think in a couple of cases we'd
say it's not surprising that it took so
long because it it it was rather a big
step but why why you know why did it
take billions of years uh in one case
why did it take thousands of years in
the case of the Enlightenment we don't
know but it appears it happens that way
by the way that's not in case you're
going to ask this is not punctuated
equilibrium uh this is not a substantive
theory about how or why adaptations or
knowledge happens it it it's not that
it's not that there's an equilibrium
like I think in none of these cases was
there an equilibrium they they all of
them were unstable to this thing
happening um so there wasn't an
equilibrium and um the
punctuation didn't have anything to do
with how it then uh went on it it it
could have gone unstable in a different
direction so this punctuated equilibrium
as advocated by goul for
example in my view is not a theory of
evolution it's just a a at best it's a
it's a description of what sometimes
happens yeah okay but is it I'm all the
words you're using about you know
lasting a long time then suddenly
something happens this sounds like phase
Transitions and meta stability to me as
a physicist uh yes uh so in in some of
these so the difference between phase
Transitions and all this other stuff is
that um we can understand um we we can
form a theory of when a phase transition
is possible and then when it will happen
and if it's too complex to work out then
we can produce a better theory of it
that work that that predicts it better
and high level Theory and so on so it's
kind of deterministic thing and all the
other things that I said are
indeterministic things they they are
things that some people would say
they're probabilistic but I think that's
not a good enough uh take on it either
um because uh they're not something
where the probability of it plays an
important role in why it happened you
know if if multicellular life uh had a
probability of 10us 6 or 10us 7 neither
you know per unit time or something
neither of those explains anything and
if we were told that that um M the
probability of multicellular life um
evolving per unit time was was
actually um uh one in in um a million
years um you know we'd be wondering why
it's a billion yeah but but saying it's
a million doesn't help to explain why it
was a billion you know it we need we
need something else something
substantive uh are you pointing toward
having a theory of why these things can
bubble along unchanging for a long time
and then suddenly change gears no I'm
just okay being being blindly critical
of um expecting everything to be known
or expecting every regularity or
irregularity in nature to have an
obvious explanation some of them have an
explanation and when we find an
explanation that's great that's uh you
know and I expect event we will find
explanations for all these things uh and
uh but I
I I I don't like the this jumping into
thinking we we know almost everything
now we we know almost
nothing during the pandemic I was I was
tweeting uh you know all the time it's
this isn't known you know why why are
you writing as if this is known whatever
it was you know um
it it's a lot of things were not known
and a lot of things still aren't known
that's perfectly Fair yeah so you you
point in the talk to the origin of life
as something that really changed things
that in a real sense for billions of
years the things that existed in the
universe were the same things that
existed a billion years prior and and
something very very new has come on the
scene now yes so the new thing um is
knowledge uh and knowledge of particular
kind
in in all these cases and um some people
will say well why is that particularly
important you know knowledge is
important to us humans because our in
our ecological niche depends on creating
and manipulating knowledge but as as I
say in my book uh you know if if if
koalas could speak then they might say
that eucalyptus leaves are important and
the emergence of eucalyptus leaves was
now I don't think that is so because
knowledge is different from eucalyptus
leaves uh both um from the point of view
of understanding it and from the point
of view of um it affecting things right
so um in terms of it affecting things um
an example that I like to cite is that
um we will soon be in a position where
our plan or the planet Earth will soon
be in a position where if asteroids or
comets head towards it they will be
repelled right rather than attracted for
all we know every other planet in the
universe attracts asteroids and and
comets and ours will be the only one to
repel now that's that's um you know I
don't need to say anything
anthropocentric MH to to note that fact
that's a physical fact and it's the same
as the other kinds of physical facts
where where we say you know this is this
phenomenon is different from that
phenomenon or we want to explain why and
the the explanation in this case is that
there is explanatory knowledge on the
earth and you I like the way that you
put it that in most cases in the
universe if I'm going to paraphrase here
but Big Things Push little things around
yes and knowledge has flipped that on
its head in some sense yes so that
that's that is exactly the explanation
for for this purely physical thing that
we we have noticed and then it's also
true the other way around that if we try
to if you try to understand what's
happening on Earth um then um you will
see again the example I give is that you
you will see uh um
people in in in the Laboratories where
they are looking for extraterrestrial
intelligence um they will have a
champagne bottle in the fridge ready for
an event that they are hoping hoping for
and if you were an alien looking down on
the earth with ultra high power
telescope and you and you noticed that
the that champagne bottle was there and
you wanted to predict something about
that champagne bottle it always be there
will it will it stay there uh when will
the cork pop out you know that that sort
of thing in order to and you'd see that
there it's not just seti I gave the
example of seti but but really any team
that is looking for a breakthrough might
have such a champagne bottle in their
fridge in their department and if you
want to understand the behavior of those
champagne bottles
you must understand not just humans not
just what happens on Earth not just
humans you must understand whether
there's extraterrestrial life whether
quazars do this or that yeah uh Dark
Matter Dark Energy you need to
understand basically everything before
you can understand how champagne bottles
behave on the surface of the Earth and
that again is because of the peculiar
properties of planetary knowledge I mean
maybe go into that a little bit more I
mean certainly um it is a feature of
life even in primitive organisms that
you know living organisms have some
information about their environment and
use that they leverage it right and
human beings do so in a very more
dramatic way uh are you pointing to the
latter there yes uh so you might say
this is only a quantitative effect but
the difference
between um as Richard Dawkins says you
know every genome has got a blueprint of
the environment that that caused it so
the environment that that caused um bats
or birds or something tells us something
about you know if you didn't know the
Earth had an atmosphere you might be
able to infer it from The genome of bats
or Birds but that's very parochial that
that's that's the the the amount the
amount of the world that affects that
genome is is very tiny by Cosmic
standards
whereas the the connection that I just
mentioned goes all the way to quazar and
to the big bang and and uh to to the end
of the universe and and and so on
there's nothing that nothing in the
physical world that can't affect those
champagne bottles and only only only via
the the
intercession of explanatory
knowledge and do you think that it's
fair to attribute that to specifically
humans here on Earth I mean there's
going to be a debate about what
non-human species really understand so I
I I prefer in in when talking about
these deep things I prefer not to refer
to humans specifically because uh if
there are are extraterrestrial
Civilizations for example then they will
necessarily have this property too sure
because they couldn't have become
civilizations and uh you know make
flying sourcers and so on without
explanatory knowledge and the same will
be true once we have artificial general
intelligence they will also be have this
properties I I prefer to talk about all
those kinds of things kinds of entities
as people
humans are people extraterrestrials are
people agis will be people and I I argue
in my book that there's nothing beyond
that that like that there may be there
may be uh agis that that think many
times faster than we do but there aren't
any that are in in principle capable of
like connecting the universe with
champagne bottles any more than we can I
that's a crucial point I wanted to get
into that so you think that we have
crossed some
threshold uh where things that are
understandable we can understand in some
sense yes um I I think we have and uh I
I think I have a watertight argument for
that but uh the the so what is that well
so it's in two parts so I think I think
human brains um have two kinds of
universality that that are essential to
this one of them is fairly
uncontroversial among sort of
scientifically minded people and the
other one is very controversial but I
think just as uh just as compelling so
the one that's that's uncontroversial is
that um our brains are touring complete
right that is um we can execute any
program that can be executed at all now
you know might take us more than a
lifetime uh it might require more memory
than we have but we can augment our
memory we can augment our lifetime
either by living longer or by having a
tradition of doing certain things uh
over Generations so those things aren't
aren't uh essential you know we're
accustomed to saying that the computer
the computers that we're having this
conversation over uh are touring
complete M even even though they have
only finite speed and finite memory
capacity but we know that that's those
are trivial restrictions because they
can however complex the program that we
want to execute with them we could do it
if we had a bit more memory and a bit
more speed maybe for the audience uh
Define what it means to be tour
incomplete oh this was defined by uh
Alan Turing uh in in 1936 when he set up
the modern theory of computation
and uh he um invented these what we now
call what we now think of as as rather
strange
computers um but they were strange they
made of paper tape and and could move
backwards and fall forwards via a reader
and he proved
mathematically that um the that a
particular one of these could compute
anything that any other one could and
this this was a bit of pure mathematics
yeah he also conjectured that the set of
all of them was the set of all things
that could be computed the set in other
words that his model of computation was
complete that there's nothing could
compute any more than that he
conjectured it but once we went to uh
Quantum computation I was able to prove
that given quantum theory so if quantum
theory is false it might still be false
but but if quantum theory is true then
conjecture is now proven so uh we know
that there's only one kind of universal
computation and then there's nothing
beyond that I I think that that's maybe
people have heard that before but I
think maybe it just hasn't made as much
of an impression as it should I think
this is worth shouting from the rooftops
right like not only can we calculate
things and compute things but we have
very good reason to believe that even if
we're slow and we make mistakes and
whatever but the kinds of computations
that can be done are kinds we can do yes
so we're we're we're as confident as we
can be that when the aliens visit us or
when the AGI become our new overlords
that they will not be able to com
compute non-turing computable functions
right uh so that's as as uh or or more
more um known to us
than than um other other bits of science
or bits of physics so um so that's
that's the uncontroversial right part
although you you say many people aren't
you know there not not so familiar to
many people yes uh the other part is I I
think um and that's that's a by the way
T incompleteness is a property of
Hardware it's a property of the brain
it's a property of comp
computers um the other kind of
universality explanatory universality is
a property of software which I say we
have uh we have that prop our software
has that property and no other
surviving um organism on Earth has
explanatory universality although we
know basically for sure that there used
to be species related to us on Earth
that also had explanatory universe
and they died out which is should be a
warning to us what do you what do we
have in mind there well like
neanderthals and uh I think going back
to um Homo erectus I mean anything
anything that had
campfires um uh necessarily
has the thing that we have there there
is only again there aren't gradations of
it in the same way there aren't
gradations of touring universality you
either have it or you don't it's
possible that you're rather impeded in
using it because you don't have enough
memory or whatever but but the basic
thing is is All or nothing and I think
the same thing is true of explanatory
universality
because uh this if I can put it in my
idiosyncratic way which I like the the
um it's to do with optimism so the
principle of optimism is that everything
which is not forbidden by laws of
physics is possible with enough
knowledge and the argument for that is
that if there was something that was
forbidden sorry that was permitted by
laws of physics but could not be
attained no matter what touring
computable program we ran in our brain
to to do the thing then it wouldn't be
the the that is it wouldn't be possible
and we could then test the scientific
theory that that thing isn't possible
after all and that what we thought of
were laws of physics were in fact not
sufficient laws of physics there there
would be no matter how we tried no
matter what we tried we wouldn't be able
to do this thing like you know exceeding
speed of light or whatever but it would
be like that but if if it was um you
know building a certain Tower or
building a certain Society you know I
either either it's forbidden by the laws
of physics or it's permitted because if
it weren't permitted then you could do
this experiment and by the definition of
science you could you could set up a
refutable theory and and so on so I
think that's that's um I think there's
no getting round that and therefore I I
think that just as there is only one
kind of Hardware universality there is
also only one kind of software
universality and that's the kind we have
do we have uh a definition of
explanatory universality that is as
rigorous and mathematical as tur
completeness no okay um because um that
there's a quite deep reason for that
explanations it it's because you can't
formalize the notion of an explanation
you can always invent new modes of
explanation and they are conjectures
like like any Theory so you might
conjecture that so and so is a good mode
of
explanation um and there the openness of
science is connected with the non
formalizable of explanation and by the
way that's exactly the same as the non
formalizable of
mathematics ah okay so uh you know you
you can't formalize what is a valid
proof because however you formalize it
you can prove that there will be
mathematical truths that can't be
reached by that by that uh formalism so
is it then fair to say that even if we
don't have a rigorous mathematical
definition of explanatory universality
we have a rigorous mathematical
understanding that we never will have
Rous mathematical definition yes okay
yes actually interesting point I never
thought of that but yes I think we do
okay good very good to know but uh this
leads you to I want to sort of finish up
the monotony discussion by reinforcing
your optimism that you already mentioned
uh you you make a good case you know
gently laying it out that we're just at
the beginning of truly transforming the
universe based on uh this knowledge and
explanatory power that human beings have
developed yes I I think that is
necessarily true uh because it it the
openness and the unboundedness are
really the same thing and and again the
same thing is true of mathematics I mean
that we we know that there's an infinite
amount of mathematics to be discovered
uh even though there in the case of
mathematics there's a lot of it that we
can't discover unlike unlike
uh uh unlike in the optimism case but uh
although I have I I have a conjecture
that we can discover all the interesting
things which are also
[Music]
okay well you you have mentioned a
couple times AGI artificial general
intelligence uh I take it that you're
relatively optimistic that's on the way
uh depends what depends what time scale
you're talking about yeah I don't I I
think we do not have the slightest clue
how to make an AGI okay I I think the
the what's standing between us and
making an AGI is is an explanatory
Theory it'll be a a largely a
philosophical Theory rather than a
computer science theory or mathematics
or physics or anything like that it'll
it'll be a new way of looking at what
creativity is what explanation is and I
think that qua comp qua computation qua
computer program I would expect it to be
very simple relativ simple so it's not
going to be reached
by more and more billions and and
trillions of of bits of data um it
that's not the kind of thing it is we we
we differ from uh monkeys who have
brains very similar to ours we or Apes
we the great apes we differ from the
great apes only by a few K of of code in
that FK of code is is the bootstrap
program yeah or bootstrap strapping um
this qualitatively different type of
program that we run um you know
infinitely
different so I you asked how optimistic
I am on the one hand I think that with
hindsight we'll we'll realize that there
wasn't much to it like all all we have
to do is is write this program of a few
K yeah and we're done on the other hand
I see no sign of the of the philosophy
that that would that would allow us to
do that um and it's rather like the
question of what is life what what what
that was like in say 1800 people had
some you know people want some people
wanted life to be explicable as an
ordinary physical process without any
Supernatural MH without any magic
without any God uh just laws of physics
and no one knew how to do that they they
had vague ideas like like Lamar and and
Darwin's grandfather had ideas that that
maybe it happened gradually maybe it
happened very slowly they didn't have
the idea of
genes uh and they didn't have the idea
of mutations and natural selection and
that solved it and you could write down
that idea in one paragraph
easy um Darwin felt the need to write a
whole book and probably rightly because
because from that paragraph nobody with
him would have understood it and I it's
possible that the the idea that will
open the door to AGI is that kind of
idea it'll it'll there will come a time
when everybody thinks it's obvious and
that and that we in our time were being
obtuse for not seeing it but from from
this end it might be very very difficult
but it sounds like it also could be an
example of what we started by talking
about of we're percolating along in a
kind of steady state for a while and
then there'll be a sudden change yes
hard to predict that's certainly was the
case with with Darwin and it it also was
the case with Turing yeah that you know
babage and love lace had had the idea
they very nearly had the idea but they
were unable to persuade anybody they
they thought it was really important no
one else did yeah and then touring I
don't know how long touring's idea would
have percolated if it hadn't been for
the second world war so uh you know
although I I don't think it would have
been centuries but you know it it might
have been couple of decades more yeah um
before anyone thought of actually making
these things which which you know people
thought of this as being a bit of
mathematics it's it's very hard to get
into that mindset because we've got
computers all around us I I'm wearing
one on my wrist
you know that that would have been an
alien conception 100 years ago so it
there does seem to be some similarity
here but you'll you'll tell me whether
it's a real one or not between this idea
of uh you know our our ability to do dur
in complete calculations get explanatory
universality now now we puny humans can
change the universe in a profound way
does that have anything to do with
Constructor Theory which is another
thing that you that you have uh
introduced to the world yes I can't yet
give chapter and verse but I think it's
very much to do with it um the uh for
example in the theory of
computation um you know the first thing
we we work out or the touring worked out
in theory of computation is that there's
a distinction between functions from the
integers to the integers that can be
computed and those that can't be
computed MH uh similarly in physics we
have physical Transformations that can
be brought about and ones that can't be
brought about so going fast than light
can't be brought about going uh to the
Moon can be brought about so there's
this distinction the basic idea of
Constructor theory is that all the laws
of physics can be expressed in such
terms in in terms of a distinction
between what can be brought about and
what can't be brought about and then and
we haven't done that yet and we've
basically done it for quantum theory
which was the easiest case and we were
kind of modeling modeling The
Constructor theory on the existing
quantum theory very conducive to it and
my colleague Kiara moletto has also done
it for
thermodynamics so once we have done that
as it were or at least conceptually once
we have got understood what expressing
all the laws of physics in constructive
theoretic terms would look like then we
can ask the next question to ask
actually I'm already asking it but I'm
jumping the gun uh is there a universal
Constructor okay now Von nyman asked
that question but that's only because he
gave up on the idea he he uh he wanted
to have a theory of Constructors what
what we would Now call Constructors uh
in order to understand what life is uh
this is before DNA and before DNA was uh
discovered and invented what the theory
was discovered
um but he was unable to and so he
invented the theory of cellular
autometer instead and he invented a
theory of universal Constructors within
the theory of cellular autometer but
that's not what we want in physics that
what what we're trying to do is to set
up a theory of of Constructors and of
the universal Constructor within
physics so now then is there and we
don't have a proof but again it's very
connected with the principle of optimism
is there a principle that says the
things that can be Transformations that
can be brought about are precisely the
ones that a universal Constructor could
bring about um and um that's as you see
I mean you're nodding so I I I see
you're sympathetic to the idea that this
is close to philosophical idea of of
optimism and and so on and also that
means that human bodies are a kind of um
hybrid thing like our our brain is is
both the controller of a universal
Constructor which is the human body
because the human body can or at least
in corporation with others can build a
computer which which can build a
universal Constructor and and so so on
but it's
also it's also the programmer it's also
the entity that creatively invents the
programs which a universal Constructor
is not allowed to be creative it has to
be perfectly
obedient so obedient is the opposite of
creative yeah so um it it has to the the
universal Constructor is like a
universal computer like if it's not
going to obey its program it's not a
universal computer and same with the
universal Constructor but our body as
you said earlier you know it's imperfect
obviously it doesn't always obey what we
tell it to do but those are errors which
can be corrected and in principle these
Corrections can be achieved with
sufficient knowledge so it's all down to
knowledge so Constructor theory is all
down to knowledge
ultimately and same with epistemology
and same with everything and we we are
going to get there but I I guess I would
I would just like to clear up I did did
have Kiara marletto on the podcast
before we had a wonderful
conversation yes but but even though I I
understood much more after talking to
her about Constructor Theory than I did
before I I still think there's this
lingering sort of naive physicist's
question which is if I have a planet
orbiting a sun and I know it's position
and velocity Newton's Laws tell me how
to calculate Kepler's laws that will go
in an ellipse and things like that how
or why should I think about that kind of
problem in terms of what can possibly be
done and what cannot possibly be done I
mean why is that a useful or or alloud
uh reformulation well it's not a
reformulation so that type of question
like like um what will the planet do you
know will it move in ellipse and that
kind of thing that's a um that set of
those questions is a subset of those
that we really want to know so for
example we want to know um are we safe
from to to take a take a thing we
mentioned earlier are we safe from
asteroids yeah well for that we want to
know what kind of
asteroids can be deflected okay now
existing ways of formulating physics
will can answer questions like what
kinds of asteroids can be deflected with
chemical rockets and and uh telescopes
that see the asteroid from such and such
a distance and so on but we're not
really interested in that
or yes in the immediate sense we are but
what we really want is to be safe and we
want to to be able to say uh protecting
the Earth is possible then we can work
out what kinds of things would be needed
and then we can use the existing type of
laws of physics to work out um
numerically What will what will be done
here but it this is different from um
this is different from say can we visit
other stars
well there we've we've got a hard limit
of the speed of light so then then the
you know if you ask a constructive
theoretic question about that you will
immediately come to what do you mean by
visit you know okay some types of visit
are possible some types of visit are
impossible and that is uh
compulsory provided that the laws of
physics are what we think they are in
other words provided that their
dichotomy the dichotomy that the
existing laws make between the possible
and the impossible uh
is what we think it is it might not be
you know constructed Theory doesn't
won't claim to be the final truth about
everything or even anything but I guess
the the thing I'm still not clear on
then is uh Constructor Theory might say
that a planet can move in an
ellipse uh is it supposed to also be a
way of figuring out the planets move in
ellipses or does it just say refer to
Newton's laws for that so it's not
Constructor Theory itself it it so
constructive theory is a kind of metal
law like the conservation of energy or
something to derive a actual
experimental conclusion from the
principle of conservation of energy you
have to know what the energy of a
particular type of object is as a
function of its parameters yeah you know
it's half MV squ or something there
kinetic energy now if you didn't know it
was half mv^ s the principle of
conservation of energy would tell you
nothing about how it moves fair so can
that principle is a framework within
which theories can be formulated so if
we formulate a theory that violates the
principle of conservation of energy we
know that we we're postulating something
very significant yeah because we
consider that principle to be to be an
overarching principle that that governs
other laws now Constructor theory is
intended to be such an overarching
principle so things can be expressed in
constructive theoretic terms and the in
other words in terms that that that will
say for example uh what can be done to a
planet uh to make it do a certain thing
what what
transformation can be done to it and
what can't and now special case of that
is supposing you don't touch it uh what
can be done to it without doing anything
to it okay but that's a tiny minority of
the of the possible interesting
questions and the one of the I would
imagine hoped advantages of Constructor
theory is that it it kind of crosses
levels right I mean we can talk about
biology and chemistry and physics all
under the same umbrella yes very much so
and uh so I probably Kiara already told
you that thermodynamics is a prime case
of this because in thermodynamics we
really don't want to know what the
specific physics of the of the um stuff
we're dealing with that that do work and
have heat and so we we want principles
that transend that and and talk in terms
of those uh so we we want to say for for
all theories that govern a thing you
can't convert all its heat into work
right and if you had a theory that
violated that you'd be doing you you'd
be proposing a momentous thing yeah and
you you'd be proposing that that the
second law is false and that that kind
of thing and we we're hoping that the
same thing will be true of Constructor
theory that that there will be momentous
principles of Constructor Theory which
which on the one hand will constrain
other theories and on the other hand
will give a deeper understanding of why
subsidiary theories other theories have
the properties they do like we know why
why kinetic energy in the Newtonian
approximation is half mv^ s and not half
MV
cubed and we know that because we've got
a deeper
formalism now underlying that which
Newton laid down which Newton didn't
know anything about energy right but but
but we know now um actually I think he
did uh I I read somewhere that that uh
uh you can ask Julian Barber about this
I think Newton did
know um a lot about what we now call um
modern theory of Dynamics or lran or
hamiltonian Dynamics but he decided not
to include it because it it was
irrelevant to what he wanted to show he
like he wanted to have three laws of
motion better than five yeah you know so
uh and exactly how you work this out
well he didn't know the immense power of
modern ways of expressing
his theory uh so I I think he wrote down
some of these laws and uh like Galilean
invariance for example he definitely
knew about right that he definitely knew
about yeah it is interesting um so I I
perceive dimly Through The Mists uh a
connection or at least an intellectual
Affinity between the idea of separating
out possible Transformations from
impossible ones and a kind of paparian
epistemology about you know possible
worlds that are allowed by the data and
and possible worlds that are not is that
am I making that up or is that there in
your head too that's definitely there um
so uh POA taught us uh that the the
content of a theory is of a scientific
theory is in what it rules out and uh
you know if you if you just took that
seriously as the basis of Your World
viiew you'd immediately come to
construct a theory because then You' say
what rule it rule out and what doesn't
it rule out and and the distinction
between those two is the theory uh POA
never said that uh you know if he had
said that then then he could have
discovered Constructor there you go yeah
um but yes it's it's very much connected
and uh it's also connected with at the
same time it's also connected with
optimism because Papa's um
philosophy um you know he he explicitly
said it's our duty to be optimistic
rather than I forgotten the quotation
but it's something like rather than
complain about how things are it's our
duty to make things how they ought to be
and something like that okay um so all
these things are connected yes and and
so I let me confess uh maybe you already
know this but I have long been an
evangelist for basian reasoning and
epistemology and uh I I'm fascinated by
the fact that you more or less
thoroughgoing reject it uh or at least
you know in in certain cases so I mean
explain explain what your objections are
to that because it's it's subtle but
potentially super important yeah I think
it is super important but it's not so
quite a lot of different things are
called basanis yeah and uh I I don't
know which of them you are you know
actually attached to right and which
kind of come along for the ride so I I'm
I specifically object to basian
epistemology which is the uh theory that
that um theory of knowledge that
knowledge consists of propositions in a
in a rational mind Each of which is
accompanied by a number not not
literally but but implicitly principle
yeah and that these these numbers
uh obey the probability calculus and
that uh when we say that um we have
improved our Theory we mean that we've
increased we've object when we say that
we've objectively improved our Theory we
mean that um we've increased the
Credence the probability of true
theories and
decreased the the probability of false
theories yeah so um I i' I'd rather not
call that thing that those numbers that
are supposed to be in the brain I rather
not call them probabilities at all so I
try to only call them credences that's
fine so that they the because they are
um I first of all I don't think they
exist and secondly if they do exist POA
and Miller prove that they don't obey
the probability calculus so uh and
couldn't so um uh what and and the key
to understanding what POA and Miller did
and as you know I'm writing a paper
about this with my other colleague um
matiash
leonardis um we have been writing it for
years um so uh it's it's quite a thing
to get one's head around but the the the
thing we think is the key
nowadays um is that um increasing your
Credence so okay let me backtrack a bit
sure if we were talking about logic then
it would be the case that if you prove a
theory logically you've also proved all
its consequences right no matter how
arcane the consequence you know you
prove this you can't both assert uh a
hypothesis and deny any of its
implications now the the thing to
concentrate on in in
why basian ism is a basian epistemology
sorry is is a bad idea is that this
isn't true of probabilistic reasoning so
um you can have some evidence that
increases your Credence for a theory oh
and now I have to stress that I'm now
talking in terms of credences which I
don't think exist so rather than we'll
let you do it sorry we'll let you do it
we
theal of your statement yeah yeah so
rather than say at the beginning I I'll
say at the beginning that in arguing
about Bas in epistemology almost every
sentence would have to be prefixed what
with assuming that credences exist and
obey the probability calculus good then
so and so okay um so um uh so the key is
that that a um a piece of evidence can
increase the Credence of a general
theory while decreasing the Credence of
the credences of its consequences and uh
then one has to ask um which
consequences because we're only
interested in some of the consequences
of a theory so you know it might be that
it only ever decreases the Credence of
some uninteresting MH um consequences
and when poer and Miller proved their
theorem some people took that attack in
in criticizing it and saying well yes it
decreases the Credence of of some of its
consequences but those aren't
interesting consequences so
um but poer and Miller also showed that
that they actually provided approved a
Criterion for which consequences are
have their credences increased and which
have their credences decreased and um
the the
um uh the answer is the ones that have
the the the credences increased the most
are the ones that just restate the
evidence in other words um the ones who
whose credences are increased but not
that much are ones that are very close
to the evidence you know uh and and then
there are most of them most of the
consequences uh the ones that are not
implied in whole or in part by by the
evidence um I should say that implying
in part is a can of worms because all
theories imply tooies yeah therefore um
a theory and its negation and you know
everything so so there's no way of
ripping apart uh the cons one set of
consequences for another to from another
this is why it takes a long time to
write the paper I get it yeah yeah yeah
U they just they just wrote down that
they were satisfied writing down the
truth it it didn't it only took three or
four pages they sent it off to to uh um
I think um British Journal for the
philosophy of science and also to Nature
the papers were
accepted some people got very angry and
most people didn't notice and we think
that everybody should notice and and
nobody should get very angry uh this
this just uh so their theorem shows that
uh that the only way that interesting
consequences of a theory have their um
Credence increased is if they had to
have a lot in common logically with the
evidence if they're just either
restating the evidence or almost
restating the evidence now is that is
that necessary or does that happen
depending on what your other possible
propositions are um it uh so we we the
way we prove it is we take the set of
all possible propositions uh expressed
in terms of possible universes I quite
like the that that framing so uh a
proposition or a theory again it's a bit
like Constructor Theory uh a
proposition uh sets up a dichotomy
between the
universes uh which uh whose existence is
denied by that proposition in other
words the universes which couldn't exist
if the proposition is true or couldn't
be the real one if the proposition is
true and those that could still be the
real one if the proposition is true you
can you can express it in terms of the
set of all propositions or the set of
all dichotomies between between
universes that can and and can't exist
um according to a particular proposition
another thing it's independent of so if
you're a basian so there's my prefix
again if you a basian you will want to
have a probability distribution function
over that set of propositions yes and
you'll want it to obey the probability
calculus um uh now POA Miller theorem is
independent of what that distribution is
so long as it obeys the probability
calculus and obeying the probability
calculus just means there numbers
between zero and one that add to one yes
but there's also relative
probabilities yeah so yes that that's
just that's all that set of ideas yeah
okay yeah the result that about the
result about uh the only things who
whose Credence goes up are the ones that
are basically restating evidence or
something like that is
independent of the priors it's
independent of the prior uh probability
a Credence distribution function okay so
their theorem is true regardless of
credence distribution function not that
there aren't other things very wrong
with the idea of a Credence distribution
function but at the moment we're
assuming uh we're assuming basian
epistemology and I should say that other
parts of what's sometimes called basian
ISM for
example uh the fact that it's a common
mistake to to use um AB absolute
probabilities when one should be using
uh relative probabilities and that's a
common mistake that one should avoid
making that's Untouched by the B theorem
that's true and you know we have no
quarrel with that it's just basing
epistemology that is the theory of
knowledge that says that we obtain
knowledge by increasing our Credence for
True theories uh that's the thing that's
false so what is there is it possible to
articulate what explicitly go goes wrong
with an idea that I would happily you
know tell people that for example we
have two theories of dark matter we have
their weekly interacting massive
particles or their axons and we have
some credences uh on one the one theory
is right the other theory is right and
we go out and do an experiment and we
rule out some of parameter space and now
we can use bases theorem to adjust our
credences accordingly is that okay or is
that problematic in your
uh that the way you said it literally
yeah is very problematic okay but what
what you're informally referring to
happens all the time and is perfectly
legitimate and so let me try and um say
what the difference is so um the picture
of knowledge and the growth of knowledge
that we have in in basing epistemology
is that all these propositions are kind
of in the frame you know we we're trying
to rule out some of them uh increase our
Credence for others in real life what
we're seeking is good explanations and
they are very rare and they do not obey
not only do they not obey the calculus
of probabilities they don't even
obey um uh ordinary logic in this they
don't model ordinary Logic for example
my favorite example the negation of a of
a of an explanation
is never an
explanation so uh if you say um uh the
the gravity is is caused by the
curvature of SpaceTime that's a theory
uh that's an explanation of uh you know
an amazing explanation of of why we
appear to feel forces and all that to
say gravity is not caused by the
curvature of SpaceTime doesn't explain
anything it doesn't even purport to
explain anything uh like it might be
part of your uh psychological Journey
from from Einstein's theory to quantum
gravity or something but it in itself
doesn't tell you anything about quantum
gravity it it doesn't you know I can
prove that to you now because we don't
have a theory of quantum gravity that
works so I can prove to you now that
merely saying Einstein's theory isn't
true doesn't tell you anything about
Quant gravity so so that means that the
whole you know if even logic doesn't
model what we're doing then certainly
probability calculus doesn't and then
there's this um Paradox of the
intransitivity of support which as the
logicians call it there there was a
logician called hemple who many decades
ago proved some theorems and uh so I I
uh can I quickly explain like what
intivity is again I I just it's just to
stress that increasing the Credence for
a theory does not increase the Credence
of its consequences typically only only
very rarely does it and those are the
uninteresting cases let me borrow the
the the Linda example uh you
know Carman and and so on so yeah you
have Linda who is uh who we're wondering
whether whether she's um a banker and a
feminist so Linda's going to turn out to
be a banker and a feminist and so by the
way this isn't the caraman thing I'm
just stealing the example yes we are
interested in the theory that Linda is a
banker and a feminist that that's going
to be our theory that we're wondering
about so then we find that that she's a
banker uh you know we get evidence of
that we see her going to a bank every
day to work and so on and we we we have
increases our credence to nearly one
that that she is a banker that will
support uh our theory that she's a
banker and a feminist and once we
believe that she's a banker and a
feminist we can go on to deduce
logically that she's a feminist so we've
gone by probabilistically from her being
a banker to her being a banker and a
feminist and from that we've gone
logically to being being a feminist but
her being a banker is no kind of support
for her being a feminist so it there's
non there's a non-transitivity there in
fact her being a banker is probabilistic
evidence against her being a feminist
that is assuming the that the Prejudice
is embedded in that example for purposes
of the story yeah we'll go with the
prejudices yes so um so you have Banker
sort of uh being a banker supports being
a banker and a feminist being a banker
and a feminist supports because it
implies being a feminist so a implies b
b impli sorry a supports b b supports C
but a counter supports C and so what
what poer and Miller perhaps should have
asked at the beginning of the paper is
which implications of a Theory are
supported by evidence that supports the
theory and they should have said then we
shall prove actually very few of them so
I guess I I don't quite see the force of
this example in this case because uh I I
completely agree that the evidence that
Linda is a banker increases Credence
that she's a banker and a feminist it
also increases our Credence that she's a
banker and not a feminist yes so
absolutely true so I don't see how I
would overall increase my Credence that
she's a feminist just from that evidence
well uh your Credence that she's a
feminist has has increased from what it
was before now it's true that your your
your Credence that she isn't a feminist
has also
increased uh that sounds like just a
mistake is that uh sorry I misspoke one
or other of them will increase which
highlights the issue if we trust a
theory more when and why should we trust
its implications more note that what
we're really after is explanatory theory
that that's why the original caraman
sort of example doesn't work properly
because they lure us into trying to
think of an explanation by telling us
all sorts of uh uh explanatory content
that is relevant to whether she is a
feminist or or both and then they
completely discard it and ask the
question is it more likely that she's a
banker or that she's a banker and a
feminist none of the story that we're
told before that is relevant to that
question well they were psychologists
not magicians
right yes yes well we're no no we're
scientists like we want an explanatory
Theory we would like to have perhaps in
an ideal you know Universe we would like
to have a way of deducing the true
theory but there is no such thing yeah
the only thing we can do is go for
explanatory power and go for good
explanations and the the the uh in the
case that you um talked about Dark
Matter dark matter and so on we don't
have infinitely many theories we have a
handful MH of good explanations which
are good only in in so far as
their as the other theories exist if the
other theories didn't exist any one of
those would be our explanation would be
our sole explanation and we would we
would go around behaving as if we knew
it was true that's that's the only kind
of knowledge available to to finite
beings but in this case where we have
two plausible pretty good explanations
of the same set of phenomena and we have
to make decisions about where to spend
money testing them and you know who to
hire in our physics departments how can
we not say that we have credences on
these different proposed explanations
well we can have credences as long as
they don't obey the probability calculus
that so so uh if you if you uh have a
Credence um
um wait let me first say maybe this is
relevant uh you can tell me whether it
is um the basian framework for credences
doeses not allow you not to know
something so not knowing you we don't
know which of those theories is true
we're we're we're we're um uh and and we
don't expect to get to the final truth
even once we do know more than we know
now so we're after good explanations um
that means that things we do not know
like are we in an alien simulation MH um
we don't know that that it's meaningless
to say that we're going to give that a
Credence of 0.5 or a Credence of
0.99 nor by the way is it meaningful to
to ask do we have a CED Credence for
basian um epist ology what is our
Credence for Bas in epistemology is it
one uh or is it 0.5 or is it
0.99
um now I can remove the prefix and I can
say none of those things make sense
where we decide between theories of dark
matter or theories of epistemology
according to how well they explain what
we want to explain so when we're asking
which which one we want to fund which
Theory we want to test next mhm we're
asking um not our Credence for the
theories we're asking for the Credence
of for we're asking for for judgments
about what the prospects for increasing
knowledge are so uh you know I think
that quantum theory is definitely false
I think that that um um general
relativity is definitely false and I
also think they contradict each other
and therefore my credences like if I
talk about my beliefs for those theories
they definitely don't obey the
probability calculus because if they did
my Credence for one would be one minus
my Credence for the other and yet I have
a very high Credence for both of them so
it's it probability doesn't provide a
proper model for for for my attitude
towards theories and it's the same with
the different theories of dark matter
what we what we want to do is to do an
ideally we'd like an experiment that is
a crucial test between two of them of
course after which one of them would
have zero Credence so it's not a matter
of credences going up and down uh really
Credence have provided you um uh are
confident that the experimental setup is
right uh you know doam and Quin pointed
out that we can't always be sure of that
and in fact ultimately we can never be
sure of that because they're always the
aliens with the virtual reality machine
that might be misleading us so
probability doesn't come into any of
this it
it we we want to take into account
things like um how good an explanation
was it in the first place like if it's a
good explanation can we rule out a bad
explanations that we don't have to
consider it anymore or can we fail to
rule it out in which case we'll have to
consider it more than before h how
expensive are these experiments we we do
not we cannot work out how much money to
spend on testing each experiments by
using classical decision Theory and
seeing which one has the highest
expectation value of the the um the uh
the the benefit that we will get from
knowing things or not knowing things
because we don't know what the outcome
is going to be the
outcome you know the best thing that can
happen in experiment is that you get an
outcome that you didn't foresee but if
you didn't foresee it you also didn't
foresee its probability what is the
probability that doing an experiment on
knocking a comet out of the way will
tell us something about Dark Matter well
we don't know but but the the we don't
know that probability and that
probability is irrelevant what we can
use is our best explanation we can see
that none of our explanations of dark
matter say that it will affect comets um
so um and if one of them did then we
would ask well can we test this or is it
the kind of theory like like well it
could be could be so which is always
true but is a bad explanation we judge
on the explanation not the probability
so if you if you're alive at the time of
uh Kepler and and um Galileo and those
people then
um you're not looking for a high
probability Theory the the the theory
that the planets move on
epicycles has got a far higher
probability than that they move on
ellipses because an ellipse is a kind of
epicycle so so by by the uh Linda
argument uh Galileo should have
preferred uh the the um epicycle Theory
because it's far far far more probable
than the ellipse Theory but he didn't he
preferred the circle Theory which is
even less probable than the ellipse
Theory because given what he thought he
knew it was a better explanation because
if it's an ellipse then you've got to
explain more things there's more things
remain unexplained than if it's a circle
so you you know you ellips you know
what's the eccentricity of the ellipse
with a circle you don't have that
question so he thought there's going to
be a way of making circles work uh see
he wasn't looking for a high probability
if if anything he was looking for the
lowest possible probability that's still
viable as a theory uh and that that's
what we do in in in in um in science
when when we're looking for General
theories uh it's a bit different when
we're looking for a particular Theory
then now this comes back to um other
uses of basis theorem if if you're a a
doctor and you want to know whether a
particular patient uh has got like Deni
fever or something then and you ask them
well have you been to the Far East
lately um then um you're asking for
something Pro probabilistic and you know
if if I bend over backwards I can call
that probabalistic
it's really that he's looking at
frequencies first of all not
probabilities he's he's looking at you
know there's only a finite number of
people that have been to the Far East a
finite number who have got infected with
the Deni fever he's approximating those
frequencies of probabilities and he's
using the approximation that his
putative patient is randomly chosen from
the set of all those people which he
wasn't he wasn't but he's he's using
that because because he doesn't know but
does that mean that he's giving doesn't
know Pro uh Credence of one half no he's
using it because he doesn't have an
explanation of the the patient's contact
with Deni fever apart from that doesn't
include going to the Far East now if if
they said well I haven't been to the Far
East but I have been to um a lecture
that was intend that was attended by um
scientists who've recently been to the
Far East then then that would change the
priors okay call those the priors but
it's just there actually just changing
the numbers in in in the in these
frequencies so there it's sometimes a
good approximation to approximate
frequencies by by probabilities by or
rather by numbers that obey the
probability calculus okay they don't
increase our knowledge you can't
increase general knowledge that way you
you can't decide between General
theories in that way because the the um
set of um uh individuals is infinite
there so it it won't work there it it's
clear that the idea of a good
explanation is kind of crucial here how
clear and formal can we be about what is
a good explanation well as as we agreed
earlier uh
you can't formalize the concept of a
good explanation yeah you
know sorry goad you know it when you see
it uh no no um so it's it's not like um
a matter of taste um it's a matter of
philosophy um so um we can make progress
in Philosophy by the same method that is
by by saying that that you know we're
going to to exclude
solipsism um
because uh solipsism could explain
anything could quote explain anything
and we're going to exclude the the
doctor saying well the patient could be
lying could have been anywhere therefore
I don't know and I've got no way of uh
assessing whether they've got Deni fever
or not you also exclude that um because
that is always true and would always
short circuit any any kind of uh trying
to approach the truth but trying to
approach the truth about General
theories um means that like solipsism or
something means that you have to adopt
the Criterion of a good explanation
because um uh well this this argument
that an explanation that can explain
anything is a bad explanation I think um
has got a
Transcendent compulsiveness about com
compellingness about it yeah um which
doesn't involve any axioms like we're
not making an axiom of of of using the
best exclamation Because if you make an
axom you'd want to have a precise
definition of the terms in the axom but
somebody like I said earlier about about
um um principle of conservation of
energy and that kind of thing if you
want to say that bad explanations are
actually accept
you've got to realize that you're
climbing up a a philosophical Mountain
by saying that you you you you can't
just say that just to justify your own
theory of you know to say that actually
mountains don't exist um because it it
anyone could say that about anything and
if you say well no I although anyone
could say it I'm saying it and there
it's allowed well that it's got an
obvious flaw in it that that way of AR
aring one thing that was very helpful
but one thing you said along the way I
can't quite let you get away with or at
least I I want to hear more namely that
you're you're pretty sure quantum theory
is false yes in what sense do you feel
that um so pretty sure and I'm not
saying I've I've uh proved it so several
things um the main one is is what I
mentioned about about this conflict with
um general relativity so in general
relativity um we we know that the
behavior of an object like a planet or
whatever uh is dependent on on the
behavior another object like the sun and
that this is mediated by a field which
travels at finite speed um we don't have
a theory of what and quantum theory
tells us like with equal confidence that
the sun isn't just in one place the the
the sun is is in a superp position or
more generally in in a mixed state where
it has many different positions
simultaneously and although some of them
are pretty close to where we see the sun
some of them are a long way away we know
that because of the um instability of
classical uh mechanics
that the the sun has been involved in
lots of uh interactions and some of them
will have been chaotic and therefore and
will have will have the end result will
have depended sensitively on the initial
result therefore these positions of the
Sun that were initially very close to
each other will get very far away and
therefore according to Quantum Mechanics
some of the suns are far away and we and
relativity does not and quantum
mechanics neither of them have a way of
telling us that the sun's effect on
planets is different in different
universes I can say that in words but I
can't say it in equations and therefore
we don't have the right equations would
would you not uh I mean I get everything
that you said but then I want to just
say there are different branches of the
wave function where there's a good
semi-classical approximation and general
relativity works pretty well um so when
I say that the theory is full I mean
that it's not true I mean I'm using the
words true and false in the sense in
which they're used in logic um there is
no excluded middle sure uh so um if if
um if it's certainly both relativity and
quantum theory are extremely good
approximations in the situations where
we want to apply them uh it's not so
clear that that we won't very soon be
applying them in other situations like
in the early Universe where we want to
explain uh something like uh the
distribution of uh microwave background
radiation over the sky um where there
there are where billions of light years
involved and uh this is all due to
something that happened on the scale
smaller than uh an atomic nucleus yeah
originally where definitely Quantum
effects were dominant and we don't know
what those were and how they affected
gravity and dark matter and and
SpaceTime and and so on so uh how close
a theory is how good an approximation is
depends on how you want to use it how
how good an approximation theory is um
so um so yes certainly good
approximations for practical purposes
but so is Newton's Theory
that's also false do you have any hints
as to how to modify quantum theory to
make it better yes I think so so there I
would have to go to Quantum field Theory
which has um uh more of a um uh internal
problem you you never mind gravity uh
just the problem of quantum field Theory
um the uh
all existing Quantum field theories are
based on axioms which include the Axiom
that fields that are space likee
separated commute with each other yeah
now that also means that that a field at
one point commutes with the future like
cone of the field at the other point and
the difference between but on the other
hand um field quantities at the same
point fail to commute M therefore field
quantities are
discontinuous
everywhere so the whole um conceptual
framework of quantum field theory is not
what it's cracked up to be now
mathematicians say okay well it's it's
not a field of it's not a real valued
field it's it's not a uh uh quion valued
field you know it it's it's it's um
uh um I've forgotten what they call it
but but but anyway the only things that
are real are the uh are the integrals of
the field over finite size right um
distribution value Fields distribution
value that's that's what they're called
yes distribution valued Fields um so but
that hasn't got a conceptual model I
mean you you can't have a distribution o
over things that don't exist so you know
you can say that only the distributions
exist but there's got to be a
distribution has to be over something
and uh so um so so anyway in short I
have an idea for a variant of Quant
field Theory where where we don't have
that axim where fields at space like
separated points are allowed
to uh uh fail to commute uh and where
the the the thing that they have to do
is be
continuous uh and
there's quite a nice Theory um again
mathematically it's quite nice but
conceptually it's
wild I I rather like
it for that reason yes yes so uh not
only do causality and that kind of thing
mean a different thing in that that
theory but measurement does as well and
uh and the separation of systems into
subsystems means something else than it
does in ordinary quantum theory and so I
I've been trying to get that theory to
work four years and um I got some nice
equations of motion for it which I don't
know what they mean but it's rather a
nice thing that that um so because of
this pathology in Quantum field Theory
it's been taken for granted that the the
way you judge proposed Quantum field
theories is by how well they let you get
round those pathologies you know whe
whether that you you have an Infinity
that cancels another infinity and so
this discontinuity is not as bad as you
might think and and so on and and on the
other hand the the ones that um uh don't
have that property are not really
considered now in in this uh
unorthodox uh Quantum field Theory as we
call it um you have a different
Criterion and the Criterion is simply
that the algebra of the quantum Fields
does not change with space and time okay
um which we have in the conventional
Theory as well except that that hardly
makes sense when it's discontinuous
everywhere so but uh and then you see
that there are only a finite number of
possible second order equations of
motion and so uh so that can be the
Criterion of the the ones that are
useful to investigate physically and
um uh I and uh another colleagues Sam
kypers have been
investigating um a easier version of
that where it's just the cubits that
don't have to commute okay different
cubits rather than field which is it's
unwieldy thing uh so you have cubits
which don't have to commute with each
other and that is another rather nice
Theory uh and it it's promising in
various ways and we are working on um
whether this could be testable like like
whether uh if you have um say a pair of
pair of photons or something coming off
a a Decay process um whether those two
photons might not commute with each
other and if they didn't what what uh
could we detect this right it it would
produce a kind of entanglement between
them that is different from the
entanglement that happens in ordinary
quantum theory ordinary Quantum field
Theory so we haven't got there yet but
that that's the kind of fun we've been
having yeah that that does actually
sound like fun does it fit into an
everan kind of formulation of quantum
theory uh yes um everettian and in the
Heisenberg picture okay
so I and we uh think that the schinger
picture is very misleading because it it
uh the Shing a state is global and it
leads leads Everett and dwit to thinking
about the whole universe of splitting
every time the state changes yeah I'm
all in favor of that well uh I think
this is too much for many people to
swallow and and they don't have to it
because in the Heisenberg picture it's
only the observables that
into and the distant universe is left
unchanged by Quantum phenomena I mean
maybe this gets into something I've
always wanted to ask you about um it I
think of worlds in the everan quantum
theory as arising from
decoherence um but I I've heard you say
things that make me think that you're
more willing to talk about multiple
worlds even before decoherence has
happened so I um in my view
um because because I I prefer to think
in the Heisenberg picture where
everything is local yeah um so there are
two situations where it is a good
approximation um um to think of quantum
physics of quantum systems as splitting
into Worlds one of them is when there's
decoherence but the other one is where
there is a Quantum computation in
progress but not just any Quantum
computation if you have a typical
Quantum computation in fact is that you
have set of worldes that are all
identical then you do something to them
that makes them different like makes
them two to the N of them and the the
the register holds a different number in
each of the two to the N universes then
you do stuff to those numbers in those
registers and then you recombine them so
um I think that during the process of
splitting uh into into multiple copies
and in the process recombining it's not
useful to think of them as being
separate universes they're all affecting
each other so much that a universe
conceptually is a quasy autonomous thing
it's a thing where classical laws almost
hold right and that's what happens
during this intermediate thing where
where you are doing a different
computation in each of of vast number of
universes the computations are classical
computations yeah okay and they're not
affecting each other each one is
autonomous and so so I think you have
there it's useful to speak of the
Multiverse as having split into
universes for a while and also when
there's been decoherence it's also there
also useful um for for like the opposite
reason because there's no hope of
recombining them well I guess yeah
that's that this is very helpful to me
because I get it now but uh it so in
that case in the quantum computation
case you say it's useful to think about
them as separate worlds because they're
evolving independently even though
they're they're not really there's
probably some sense in which they're not
classical I think uh they're classical
computations but they are classical
computations and and furthermore they do
recombine at the end of the day unlike
the decoherence example well if somebody
knocks over the computer and they never
recombine and then that happens later
then you know you can't say well
retrospectively they weren't universes I
think I think that wouldn't make sense
okay all right well you you've given us
a lot to think about uh my last question
will be am I right that you recently
mentioned that you're working on a third
book Yes actually I'm I'm working on
several books and I'm not sure you know
what I can say about about the ETA of
any of them uh so I'm also working uh
with Sam kypers and Kiara moletto on a
textbook of quantum mechanics quantum
theory um and I'm also working on a
science fiction book oh wow another uh
which which contains conjectures that I
wouldn't dare State seriously even in in
an article uh but in science in science
fiction you're allowed to but maybe you
have a Little Bit of Sympathy for these
conjectures um yes I have a bit of
sympathy for all but one which is very
horrible
okay so and that that's what makes it
dramatic you know that's that's uh uh I
don't know how to refute it I mean it
could be true but as we've just said you
know lots of things could be true lots
of things could be true and for the
quantum theory textbook is that supposed
to be uh you know a competitor first
standard second year in University well
it's a competitor in the sense that if
somebody wants to change the entire way
they teach quantum mechanics yeah okay
then this would be a way of of doing it
so Heisenberg picture would be Central
not Schrodinger ever would be Central um
uh cubits would be Central not hydrogen
atom uh and um so it's all about Quantum
information uh it's um it's close
to um um close to uh modern kinds of
experiment instead of old-fashioned
kinds of experiment yeah uh and it's um
conceptually um it doesn't have the
baggage that existing things do now I
know there are there are a couple of um
textbooks already on the market that uh
start with cubits mhm and I haven't
actually read one of them uh but I I'm
sure they don't do those other things
that we want to do so probably not I I I
will confess I'm also working on one
very slowly um but and but I I don't
know whether how to characterize it I'm
not as ambitious as you are about hoping
that people will completely change how
they think about how they teach quantum
mechanics so I'm actually even though I
think that probably I'm sympathetic to
the philosophy you put forward in this
book I'm I'm guessing but I'm going to
try to split the difference right so
that more oldfashioned people are not
quite as shocked so a little bit of
everything there yes well it'll that'll
probably sell much better than our one
no I'm not averse of that we we'll we'll
have to see but uh David do thanks so
much for being on the mindcap podcast
well thank you for inviting
[Music]
me
yeah